ils attendaient cette date du 15
décembre avec hâte et un soulagement
anticipé tant la fréquentation
touristique globale était en berne cette
année 2020 mais comme les cinémas les
théâtres ou encore les salles de
spectacle les châteaux doivent garder
portes closes
pourtant tout était prêt pour accueillir
les visiteurs et leur faire partager la
magie de noël dans un lieu chargé
d'histoire fruit d'un travail de
plusieurs semaines ces décorations
amboise et blois les conserves florent
clavel la somptueuse salle des états
généraux brillance silence
d'ordinaire vingt mille personnes se
pressent pour goûter à la magie de noël
au château de blois admirer la mise en
scène
ici les sapins bleus répondant aux
fleurs de lys mais cet hiver pour la
première fois depuis le lancement de
l'opération noël au château il ya quatre
ans personne on est complètement
déstabilisé par ce qu'on avait investi
beaucoup alors en terme financier
évidemment mais pas qu'eux en terme
humain on misait beaucoup pour
redynamiser un peu la fréquentation en
fin d'année et retrouver un peu des
recettes aussi va voilà pour l'instant
mais on attend car cette prolongation de
fermeture intervient après une année
déjà très difficile pour le monument
fréquentation plombé par les deux
confinement et report de la grande
exposition prévue en 2021
pour la conservatrice du château le
risque est de perdre contact avec un
public défavorisé
il y aura toujours des publics qui sont
qui vont vers les musées naturellement
parce que justement si leur
environnement culturel mais là on va
voir qu'on va encore davantage mettre de
côté ses publics qui n'ont pas
l'habitude culturel les allées au
château royal d'amboise
on accuse aussi le coup malgré la
mobilisation du secteur culturel peu de
chances que les monuments rouvre à noël
donc la grande crèche napolitaine qui
fait partie d un peu des pièces star des
expositions de noël comme à blois
on planche déjà sur l'an prochain avec
l'espoir de capitaliser sur les
touristes français venus en nombre cet
été une saison estivale excellence et
appartements ont été réouverts on aime
beaucoup de monde
on a eu beaucoup de monde également à la
toussaint et avant les annonces de
confinement on avait aussi pas mal de
demandes par téléphone et par mail pour
les vacances de noël
donc je reste assez confiant dans la
mesure où si nous sommes ouverts on aura
du monde en particulier sur les vacances
scolaires touristes français mais aussi
européens
en revanche elle les châteaux estime
qu'il faudra sans doute un voire deux
ans pour attirer de nouveau la clientèle
éloigné chinois et américains en tête